welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul and i'm blue dabba dee-da
but die because disney yeah they've just
dropped the first trailer for avatar 2.
the original released all the way back
in 2009 and the several sequels that
we're getting on the film have remained
a closely guarded secret since then the
movie was a box office phenomenon that
pretty much remained as the highest
grossing film of all time for the 13
years since its release avengers endgame
managed to snatch the crown back from it
only for the inevitable to happen and
once more it regained its spot at the
top however there hasn't really been
that much hype for the sequels and i
have to admit that i wasn't really that
interested i think i'd probably only
seen the first movie at the cinema when
it released and then maybe watched it
once more at home i always remembered it
being kind of mid with a heavy reliance
on 3d that lost its appeal once you
removed that however i actually went
back at the weekend and rewatched the
film and i have to say that i was wrong
and it definitely stands on its own two
feet even without the technology behind
it the movie really captivated me and
wowed me throughout without needing to
strap on massive glasses onto my already
massive glasses now i'm guessing a lot
of you were in the same boat as me where
you hadn't watched the movie since its
release so if you need a quick catch up
then the next part of the video is for
you i've left time codes below if you
already know it and want to skip to the
trailer stuff but we start off in the
forest and future of 2154 the world is
almost a barren wasteland due to
humanity using up all of earth's natural
resources and it now looks like a night
out in glasgow earlier we meet jake
sully an ex-marine who was left
paralyzed after a combat mission in
venezuela went awry jake's brother was
part of the avatar program which allowed
someone to control a host body through
their consciousness so that humans could
interact with the locals on any planet
they landed on by looking like them
however jake's brother died and due to
the avatars taking genetic material from
the person piloting them they needed a
match which came in the form of jake his
twin brother's twin brother keep up yeah
anyway along with the resources
development administration or rda for
short they headed out to the planet
pandora attempting to obtain a special
element called unobtainium which yeah i
forgot it was called that but attempting
to obtain a special element called
unobtainium jake his friend norm and dr
grace attempted to integrate with the
locals on their first day in the wild
jake was attacked by a beast called the
thanator and after he got lost in the
jungle he came across nathiri who saved
his life and here he was part of the
navi who jeg was trying to integrate
with and though she was initially going
to kill him she ended up staying her
hand after an omen from her god iowa
landed on her arrow the navi are very
spiritual and they believe that all life
exists in an ecosystem where life is
born someone lives and they go back to
the ground to be reprocessed so that
more life can come from them typical
stuff that you tell a girl at college
you're fancy because you seen her
reading a book on canals once
but concarnals anyway after taking him
before her tribe nithiri was ordered to
teach jake their ways and after training
for three months the pair fell in love
now this group of navi lived inside a
giant tree which had a huge pile of
unobtainium below it and jake was
ordered to integrate with the navi and
convince them to lose
an obtainium
however jake great
being serious however jake grace and
norm all knew they'd never abandon it
because of their connection to nature
and when the rda learned of this they
launched an attack on home tree they
ended up destroying it and after jake
grace and norm tried to warn the navi
they were arrested and held as traitors
like you when you go watch your video
from another channel i know what you've
been doing i know you've been watching
looper anyway with help from a pilot
named trudy they escaped but sadly grace
was shot and killed by the rda security
leader called colonel miles in order to
show that he was truly one of them now
jake managed to mine meld with a giant
winged beast known as a turok that only
the legendary ancestors of the tribe had
managed to tame after finding the rest
of the navy at their sacred home the
tree of souls they went out and gathered
other tribes from the planet in order to
have one final stand against the rda
attacking from the skies and ground the
navi managed to push them into a retreat
and jake went head-to-head with a
colonel however his real body was
damaged in the battle and after sending
the humans packing he ended up
transferring his consciousness through
the tree of souls into his avatar which
ended the film now as for the way of
water trailer we open with the flux
vortex and a group of the navi running a
routes that connect the floating
platforms in case you don't know this
area features a gravitational anomaly at
it and this was where the final battle
took place in the first film due to the
gravity being off kilter it messed with
the instruments used by the humans and
thus they were unable to utilize their
radar this explains later on why the
avatars being used by the humans might
ride on the native beasts of the planet
instead of remaining in their ships
whilst fighting the navy we do see more
gravitational anomalies near the ocean
areas so that makes a lot of sense to me
now at the front you might also notice a
human who pops up later in the trailer
in the jungle he ends up being pretty
close to the navi by the looks of it and
according to the wiki for the film this
is a character known as javier socorro
though the rda ended up fleeing the
planet in the first film there were
clearly some humans left behind and from
what we know in the movie javier was
born on pandora he is going to be
rescued and adopted by jake and ethiri
who have several other children we catch
you pregnant in the first look and
they're going to have three kids called
neta yam loac and took took tire
moving on now the first two of these are
sons and the last one is a daughter this
is who i believe we see skipping along
with javier at the start but it is a bit
difficult to make out exactly who they
are we then cut in a teary moving
through the jungle with a shadow of
leaves brushing past her face now i know
this film is kind of getting dunked on
for having quote-unquote ps2 graphics
but i think it looks really good
actually watch this trailer for the
first time before seeing doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness and to me
it looks stunning on the big screen now
cameron initially just announced this
movie and one more sequel however he's
gone on to announce several more movies
on top of this one so like it or not
you're gonna be getting lots of avatar
films now the main reason for the hold
up in the second one's development was
because that motion capture technology
simply didn't work underwater however
cameron and cove spent the last decade
trying to develop the tech so that they
can do it and apparently they managed to
find a way to bring this into the film
the whole movie will be centered around
the navi trying to find a new home and
looking at the cast list we know that
there will be several diver characters
this includes ronal who will be played
by kate winslet according to the wiki on
the film ronald is a pivotal character
and not only did winstead have to learn
motion capture for the movie she also
had to learn free diving apparently
winslet managed to hold her breath for
seven minutes which is a new world
record for any scene shot underwater
take that tom cruise you're bloody
furious aren't you now on top of that
there are two actors whose characters
seemingly died in the first film cameron
stated that sigourney weaver will be
returning however she will be playing a
new character rather than being dr grace
i kind of have a feeling that she might
be the voice of awa as grace's character
went into the tree when trying to
transfer between her body and her avatar
there's also stephen lang who's coming
back however his character was killed at
the end of the movie by nathiri cameron
stated that he wouldn't exactly say how
they're bringing him back but it is a
science fiction story and that it'll tie
in with that the premise of the
franchise in general is that humans have
found a way to create bodies that they
can plant their minds into certain thing
they might end up resurrecting the
character through the use of cloning
hell the version of colonel miles that
we saw in the first film might have even
been an avatar himself and who knows
miles might have been in his own pod
controlling himself from the planet
cameron also said that his character
will evolve into a really unexpected
place across the upcoming films and that
though he will predominantly be an
antagonist you might even start to see
things from the navi's point of view if
he is a clone of something that's just
being used by the rda to conquer worlds
he'll be pretty stone-cold but that
kinship with nature might open up his
eyes to another side of life now another
interesting rumor floating around about
the film is that they've managed to do
not only underwater motion capture but
also 3d without the glasses remember
your nintendo 3ds well it's that it's
that but in a cinema yeah apparently
which will be mental it'll be it'll be
bloody mental won't it now i think a lot
of the first film success was down to
revolutionizing 3d and now hollywood ran
it into the ground doing it this way
would be absolutely incredible now in
the trailer they're clearly playing out
there's gonna be way too much water to
the point ign about to give this movie a
six we catch them flying over the ocean
to trees that have their roots pushing
up so that they don't drown and gorgeous
beaches there's also a lot of sea life
such as giant gentle whales and ones
that resemble stingrays really nice
looking imagery that of course mirrors
our own world and the divers in it also
does anyone think the trailer song
sounds like wildest dreams by taylor
swift
say you'll remember me
standing in a nice dress staring at the
sunset no just me now the free diver we
see in this looks like they might be
wearing a t-shirt so this could be
similar to grace in the first film and
it might actually be a human in an
avatar it looks like the humans are
still using the avatar strategy to blend
in with the locals as we see them
constructing or perhaps repairing a base
hell's gate was abandoned in the first
film but they might be back at the
outpost as there's so much stuff there
there's a mech also walking along as
well as to avatar navi i'm not 100 sure
who this is but vin diesel has been cast
in an undisclosed role and it looks like
javier and the rest of jake's kids end
up coming across them in the wilderness
this trailer is very much about family
and who better to have in the movie now
it might have been sent in to brock a
piece though they do look like they're
part of the military god damn guys they
just won that unobtainium now we then
get a shot of the water beast so the
characters will be riding and similar to
the mountain banshees they mind meld
with them there are more gravitational
anomalies shown and what looks like an
attack on the human base led by javier
the human avatar looks pretty annoyed by
this and we later see it flooding making
me think that they've also tried to set
up shop in the oceans of the planet
pandora we later see both the navi and
humans reading themselves for a water
battle so i'm guessing that's what's
gonna happen towards the end of the film
they aren't really giving much away and
it definitely feels like one of those
trailers that could be misleading on
purpose lots of beautiful visuals though
and i am interested to see the fight
between the humans on the navy's side
whilst we also have the humans disguised
as the navi fighting against them anyway
that's a trailer a recap and some
tidbits about the film i'm really
excited to watch it and now being kind
of met on the franchise for over 10
years now re-watching it this week did
make me appreciate why it's done so well
i can't wait to see the movie when it
releases at the end of the year and this
trailer really was a blast i hope you
enjoyed the video and i'll now pass it
over to you are you excited for the film
how do you think it'll do and what are
you up to this weekend let me know below
and just to let you know we're running a
competition right now and giving away
three copies of spider-man now at home
on the 15th of may all you have to do to
be on the chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the teaser
we pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners are the
last one on screen right now so that's
you then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want emails to
watch then make sure you check out one
of our videos linked on screen right now
which is perfect for you if not get the
hell out of here i'll see you on the
next one take care peace